[Musique]
valéry giscard d'estaing je ne vous ai
jamais rencontré nous avons échangé nos
premiers mots il ya quelques minutes
en entrant dans ce studio vous avez
souhaité vous entretenir avec moi je
vous ai demandé vous avez accepté de
respecter la règle de mes conversations
radio ce n'est que cette règle ces
règles sont très simples je ne vois
jamais les personnes que j'accueille
avant l'émission
elles ne sont pas du tout au courant des
questions que je peux leur poser les
choses se passent ainsi comme peuvent en
témoigner
marché andré malraux krivine sanguinetti
mendès-france et je pourrais en citer
beaucoup d'autres n'ont pas parlé
politique
ce que je veux c'est aller à la
rencontre de l'homme que vous êtes
il y a eu après le débat télévisé qui
vous a opposé à françois mitterrand un
sondage c'est lamotte et sondage qui
fait apparaître quelques réflexions et
je les ai nos textes de réflexion vous
êtes brillant vous êtes sympathique
convaincant dynamique sincère mais vous
êtes moins à l'aise que françois
mitterrand vous êtes moins loyal moins
habiles et puis ce qui ce qui
m'intéresse aujourd'hui vous êtes moins
humain oise humain voilà la question
pourquoi moi jumain je repose la
question oui je crois que c'est une
question d'âge
ce qu'on appelle l'humain lorsqu'on
porte un jugement sur quelqu'un c'est le
fait qu'il ait connu en dur et traversé
un certain nombre de circonstances
quand quelqu'un jeunes dit pas c'est
quelqu'un d'humain on dit c'est
quelqu'un de sympathique
et puis c'est ensuite en effet plus tard
dans l'existence que l'on vous donne
cette étiquette d'humains je dirais que
être moins à l'aise être sympathique
celle ci d'une certaine jeunesse c'est
plus tard qu'on peut mériter de
qualificatif si vous estimez que vous
êtes transformé au cours de cette
campagne vous avez parlé de vous une
fois mais vous parlez de vous au passé
et ce qui nous intéresse ce qui est
interdit aux téléspectateurs le français
c'est l'homme d'aujourd'hui
l'homme que vous n'êtes que vous êtes
peut-être deviné non je ne suis pas
transformé
campagne personne ne se transformant en
quelques secondes dans les mots ces
sirops parfois ça c'est autre chose ce
ne soit pas se transformer non je ne me
suis pas transformé par ce que ce que
j'ai essayé d'être dans cette campagne
que je suis dans cette campagne c'est ce
que je suis mais l'opinion publique
avait deux mois une idée différente
il était naturel qu'elle est une idée
différente parce qu'elle avait au
travers de ma fonction
elle ne connaissait comme ministre de
l'économie et des finances et donc elle
me jugeait comme elle estime juger un
ministre l'économie et des finances mais
d'autres personnes par exemple mes amis
ou mes électeurs en nevers ne savait
très bien que ce que je suis était
différent donc les pas changé une cote
cette campagne mais ce qui est différent
peut-être c'est que ma communication le
papillon française elle a changé
vous êtes polytechnicien et énarque
certains disent que vous êtes
l'ordinateur vous avez ou les chiffres
au début de la campagne vous étiez
valéry giscard d'estaing
ensuite vous étiez giscard vous êtes
ensuite valérie on pourrait penser que
si la campagne durait encore vous iriez
tutoyer la france et je me demande si
vous êtes fait pour cette familiarité
parce que j'ai observé au cours de cette
campagne ces deux mouvements
c'est d'une part un mouvement que j'ai
fait en direction de l'opinion publique
pour exposer un certain nombre de
problèmes pour établir un certain
contact qui s'est établie et puis il ya
eu un mouvement qui a été fait en sens
contraire par l'opinion publique et qui
de son côté a apporté quelque chose dans
cette campagne apporter quelque chose à
ma rencontre je les dis j'ai été très
frappée touché par exemple lorsque je
sors des salles de réunion ou par tous
ceux qui vous disent bonne chance c'est
un mot qu'on adresse à quelqu un levier
vis de qui on établit un lien
bonne chance mais pas un mot de langage
politique c'est un beau du langage
personnel
donc je crois que ce contact très direct
entre l'opinion publique et le candidat
a pris sur soi c'est fondamental il
n'est pas de deux que vous avez de
l'ambition que vous avez le goût de la
puissance que vous avez le goût
pouvoir et on peut se poser la question
pourquoi un homme veut être président de
la république car on sait être président
de la république c'est entrer dans le
monde de la solitude dans un désert
c'est être au dessus de tout le monde et
d'avoir surtout personne dessus de soi
vous avez raison quand j'en crois pas je
nous faut faire attention à ce manque
d'ambition
c'est un mot qui péjorent hâtif il nous
va bien du scion je ne crois pas bon je
vous surprendre parce que quelqu'un qui
est là que les candidats à la présidence
de la république qui le dit à ses
compatriotes naturellement il exerce une
ambition seulement je pense aux mots
ambitions au sens habituel jeune homme
ambitieux je suis plus ambitieux dans ce
sens là je l'étais je l'étais notamment
lorsque j'étais jeune ministre parce que
j'étais fier de l'être j'étais conscient
de l'autorité que ça vous donnait du
pouvoir ça vous donnais et puis quand
j'ai quitté le gouvernement c'est à dire
en 1966 j'ai été éloigné du gouvernement
pendant trois ans et à ce moment là j'ai
mesuré les limites aurait été de
l'ambition et lorsque je suis revenu au
ministère l'économie et des finances mon
intention c'était plus ambition ce n'est
pas la satisfaction d'être ministre
c'était de mieux faire ce que j'avais
fait la première fois que j'estimais ne
pas d'avoir fait aussi bien ou assez
loin que j'aurais nous faire à l'époque
et je dirais qu'à l'heure actuelle
cardin qu'est ce qui s'est passé le
présent pompidou devait rester présent
dans le public en 1976 donc il n'y a pas
d'échéance pour l'ambition
présidentielle pour personne c'est un
événement qui a été soudain qui était
frappant
et il se trouve que j'étais parmi ceux
qui devaient se poser la question mais
je suis conscient comme vous le dites du
poids de la fosse non pas confiant parce
que j'ai peur d'être écrasés
j'ai toujours considéré dans l'existence
que lorsqu'on veut faire quelque chose
quoi que ce soit il faut tu vouloir la
chose et accepter les inconvénients de
la chose on ne peut pas vouloir être
président de la république et s'est
frayé ou se développer au poids de la
fonction poids qui est effectivement
écrasant mais ce qui m'intéresse dans
cette candidature ça n'est pas le fait
d'être nommé président de la république
c'est le fait d'avoir la chance de faire
quelque chose comme président de la
république
et si vous
la confidence lorsque le soir je rentre
de six réunions tas et qu'on pense qu'on
a un moment de tranquillité
je me dis qu'est-ce que je penserais
dans quelques années si j'étais élu
président de la république qu'est ce que
j'aurais fait est ce que j'aurai le
sentiment véritablement d'avoir accompli
quelque chose alors c'est ça si vous
voulez mon ambition
dimanche c'est une élection capitale
et si c'était une exécution capitale si
vous perdiez comment réagiriez-vous page
d'ailleurs vous êtes dans la position de
l'homme qui veut gagner
qui a gagné nous sommes deux dans 2 vous
avez gagné dans la position d'homme qui
voulons normalement gagner on le veut
vraiment on le veut vraiment oui on le
voit rouge considère les listes un choix
grave pour moi c'est un choix grave pour
la france ta choix grave pour moi dans
une certaine mesure mais c'est un choix
grave pour la france et ça me ferait
profondément de l'angoissé de la peine
doit la france se trompe et 105,7 infra
grave alors je ne raisonne pas en terme
de victoires et de défaites est vrai je
n'aime pas le cas bullaires il ne s'agit
pas d' écraser l'adversaire ou d'être
écrasé par lui il n'y aura personne de
décapiter c'est un choix il va du beige
avec la france et sur une route une
bifurcation qu'elle peut prendre l'une
ou l'autre de deux fois et si elle
choisit l'autre voici c'est l'autre voie
qu'a choisie est bien la france aura
choisi démocratiquement et pour moi je
suis quelqu'un qui suit de tempérament
et nature démocratique lorsque je dis
que je suis libéral c'est ça que je veux
dire je respecte le choix des l'autre je
vais tout faire pour que la france fasse
le bon choix
tout faire j'ai fait cette campagne je
vous parle aujourd'hui je parlerai
encore vendredi pour que la france pas
ce bon mais si elle enfin un autre je
respecterai son choix
vous avez de l'east india votre
adversaire
je considère que c'est un homme très
capable très capable et qui mène une
campagne qui est une autre planète
candidat à la présidence de la
république
j'estime que j'ai suivi comme peut-être
comme vous d'ailleurs des campagnes dans
d'autres grands pays bien cette campagne
fait pas en adversaire c'est une
campagne normale de qualité d'ac2 un
candidat à la présidence en pratique il
y a beaucoup d'adjectifs pour désigner
rôti
réfléchis prudent audacieux des
repreneurs ou les cieux le seul mot
pensant oui il vous manque peut-être
d'être un peu maladroits ont dix ans
moyennant quoi d'autres joueurs dans une
émission de télévision j'ai fait trois
petites erreurs de langage mais je n'ai
pas refait mon émission en général je
fais toujours une fois simplement et on
m'a dit ah vous voyez les fait trois
erreurs de nom alors il faut à la fois
être maladroit ne pas l'être 6 comprend
bien non juste si vous croyez que je
suis à droite pour une raison simple
je suis quelqu'un qui fait attention aux
choses et aux gens parce que je
considère que les choses et les êtres
c'est fragile et qu'il faut toujours
faire très attention il faudra mettre
brut à fulham être brusque il voudrait
trancher dans le vif comment comme on le
dit il faut au contraire faire très
attention quand vous êtes attention vous
êtes ce que l'on appelle à droit parce
que en effet vous évitez les décision
soudaine ou brusque ou les erreurs ou
les choses qui qui blessent les êtres
dans mon ministère par exemple au milieu
de mes collaborateurs avec lesquels j'ai
travaillé pendant de longues années j'ai
toujours éviter qu'il y ait des tensions
des antagonismes et lorsque chanta qu'il
en existait avant la fin de la journée
même je sais que disent pas allez-vous
changer de torts vous disant que je
serai président de la république il faut
que je sois un autre homme
échangez vos danses non je n'ai pas
changé le nom parlant tous les non c'est
pas changé de ton tout a changé de ton
si vous voulez on prend effectivement
conscience de quelque chose c'est dur
très surprenant puisque être candidat à
la présidence de la république ce n est
évidemment pas être président de
république et douce que nous étions
voici quinze jours n'étions pas présents
la république seulement quand vous êtes
amené à penser à la dimension du
problème
et comme lorsque vous parlez aux autres
les autres vous regarde en se disant
c'est peut-être un président de la
république alors vous prenez conscience
que quelque chose qui dans une certaine
mesure où chants certains coups vous
aurez mal or nous n'avons jamais vu une
trace évidente sur votre visage de ségou
reçues et vous insensible d'abord c'est
peut-être parce que ne pas bien regardé
j'ai regardé et ensuite si vous
connaissez la nature humaine comme vous
étiez fier à ce moment là même n'y ai
pas touché un homme comme vous qui la
connaît qui g7
étudier ce qui en effet ne montre pas
certaines choses
ce ne sont pas les gens insensible ce
sont les gens très sensibles
parce que si les gens très sensibles
laisse apparaître soit la blessure soit
le sentiment ils font apparaître
beaucoup pays sud où beaucoup de
sentiments je quelqu'un dans les
réactions sont très fortes dans la
sensibilité très forte et c'est pourquoi
en effet devant certaines blessures qui
existe depuis la bm pas ne les a pas
quelqu'un de secret aussi parce que le
giscard d'indre giscard d' le connais
pas non je n'ai pas qu'un de secret
c'est quelqu'un de réservé d'argent
d'abord je respecte la loi du secret
chose fondamentale et pour un homme
d'état fondamental je les dis à propos
par exemple du général de gaulle j'ai
été comme beaucoup ministre le familier
du général de gaulle puisque j'avais eu
une conversation par semaine
vous avez vu le nombre de mémoires de
citations qui ont été écrites à propos
du général de gaulle comme je
considérais que c'était les
conversations tête à tête avec le chef
de l'état
je n'ai jamais utilisé une seule de ces
conversations de ses citations les
utiliserai peut-être un jour
enfin le jour où ça ne sera plus utile
ou utilisent à dire si un jour je dois
écrire ce qui s'est passé à un certain
moment peut-être le ferai mais
certainement pas dans le combat dans la
lutte politique et je crois qu'un homme
d'état a le devoir de respecter le la
loi du secret il y a dans votre période
une suite anecdotique de situation il ya
eu l'homme vous lover
il y a eu l'homme qui prenait le métro
il ya eu l'homme qui joue au football a
jamais rien
il ya eu l'accordéoniste et encore tout
récemment vous étiez au match de rugby
qui opposait béziers à narbonne et je
crois savoir que c'est beaucoup plus
patients les renards blancs
vous n'êtes plus passionnés de football
de rugby alors je me demande si vous
êtes battus si vous irez à la finale de
la coupe de football bien sûr soulève
tous ceux ci sont des anecdotes mais
dans ses électeurs est réelle elle est
témoin d'un personnage elle sermonne un
personnage parce qu'on les interprètes
je prends le cadre de mon match de
football l'année dernière à chamalières
mon a dit que c'était un montage quelque
chose d'organisé on pouvait sans saigner
les commerçants de vivre une ordination
de commerçants avaient eu l'idée
l'occasion de la fête municipale de
chemin diact début juin de jeter à des
films on s'abonne ici parler mes
adjoints me disent que nous relevons le
défi bien sûr talent relevé défier faire
ce match donc c'est quelque chose de
leurs cales et spontanée pas du tout
d'apprêter mais ce qui est vrai c'est
que je me suis toujours efforcé et si je
suis élu président de la république je
continuerai mes forces et de faire que
les hommes d'état en france apparaissent
comme des êtres plus simple ça nous
avons derrière nous une tradition de
conventions de protocoles tout à fait
excessive et qui n'est pas moderne car
vous savez très bien dans les autres
grands pays ça n'est pas comme ça le
fait pour un président des etats-unis d'
n'apparaîtront pull-over n'aurait
intéressé ou frappé personne
il n'y a pas de ridicule notamment n'y a
pas de ridicule mais l'idée que
finalement ce sont des hommes comme les
autres qui exercent seulement des
fonctions plus importantes leur sont
confiées pour une certaine durée puisque
ce sont des hommes comme les autres
ceci est acceptée et jugé normal je
souhaite qu'en france et du rejet l'idée
d' initiatives à prendre à cet égard que
le présent d'un public va considérer que
quelqu'un d'important naturellement de
respectables mais quelqu'un qui commet
être comme mauvais temps réel comme les
autres nous et raisonnable valéry
giscard d'estaing est tous capables de
jeter ima sera elle
la raison et passion si beaucoup plus
passionné que resona puisque vous poser
la question raisonnablement passionne
donc je suis beaucoup plus passionné que
raisonnable par nature mais lorsqu'il
s'agit des choses de la raison de
l'esprit faut être raisonnable pas très
souvent on mélange les deux et il faut
pas raisonner dans un esprit passion par
exemple il ya le sujet de la passion la
souffrance le malheur la solitude
l'affection seule issue est passion tous
les passionnés et puis il ya rencontré
les sujets de la raison l'organisation
de la société les rapports des dessins
avec les autres la façon de faire
progresser telle ou telle institution il
faut être raisonnable et lorsqu'il
s'agit de traiter un sujet raisonnable
il faut le traiter une façon précède
donc la passion c'est pour tous qui
souffrent pour tout ce qui vit et la
raison c'est pour la solution des
preuves vous avez toute légalité
on se dit proche et toute légalité me
dire ce sont deux choses qu'il faut
constamment éprouvée et je pense qu'un
chef d'état qu'un président de la
république doit éprouver les deux parce
que il veut avoir le sentiment de la
quantité de l'accumulation de souffrance
et de peines de son époque à l'intérieur
et à l'extérieur les libres étant que la
france devait avoir à mes yeux une
politique étrangère libéral dans le
monde
c'est à dire une politique qui ait pour
objet d'alléger la souffrance des autres
de respecter mieux les droits des autres
pour un dessin je pense qu'on le sente
ça ne peut pas faire uniquement par la
raison la raison peut conduire au
contraire des politiques plus réalistes
et bien en même temps je dirais qu'un
prétendant public d'être un homme
raisonnable surtout en france
c'est-à-dire dans un pays qui est
toujours vous savez fragile et sujet à
certains comportements au certains
risques comment êtes-vous avec les
autres pierre autin je ne crois pas
c'est à vous menez vous interrogez non
je ne crois pas seulement d'abord honda
leur force physique et je me suis
raisonnable victime de son physique en
unies à new york the town est pas pour
grand-chose même plutôt maigre pour ça
donne une certaine apparence je suis
ainsi mais dans mes rapports personnels
avec un apport personnel sont très
direct j'avais raconté d'ailleurs dans
l'émission de télévision que par l'aide
moi mon du premier tour j'ai passé un an
et demi de ma vie comme seule la seconde
classe dans un régiment venus de
l'afrique du nord est composé pour
l'essentiel de l'afrique a dénoncé des
musulmans l'algérie qui constituait j'ai
vécu vraiment dans un milieu qui était à
mille ténue actuelle je voulais les
travailleurs immigrés en france j'ai eus
avec mes camarades avec mes amis de
l'époque les rapports les plus chien
appelé plus direct je regarde un
souvenir très fidèle d'ailleurs l'un
d'entre eux au début de tempête
électorale j'avais jamais vu depuis est
venu apporter une photo qu'il avait pris
je vais garder dans une enveloppe et où
on nous voyait tous les deux hommes de
cinq ans
il ya également les formules je veux
regarder la france
au fond les yeux bonjour et savoir ce
qu'il y a au fond des yeux de giscard
d'estaing dans les formules de ce fait
il faut voir que c'est utile vous les
préparez et formés ne viennent pas tout
seul non on est je réfléchis y ont
réfléchi un sujet puis tout à coup la
formule vient mais regardez prétendre
quelques uns des grands hommes des temps
comme au churchill ou comme roosevelt
ont toujours chercher des formules de
gaulle trouver les formules parce qu'à
un certain moment la formule illustre et
permet la population à l'opinion de
comprendre quel est l'essentiel ou
qu'ils la direction qu'on lui propose de
choisir
il se trouve que j'ai eu un certain
nombre de formules qui ont les faits ont
été connus comme par exemple oui mais
oui comme par exemple oui mais bleu oui
mais c'était une chose très simple c'est
l analyse de la situation politique du
moment et quand j'ai prononcé ce mot je
m'attendais pas du tout à ce qu'il elle
le succès ou locaux qu'il a eu par la
suite les oubliées de ragga la clause
est l'homme d'un milieu l'homme d'une
caste lorsque vous serez si vous y êtes
au sommet de votre ambition
serez vous capable de dépasser ce milieu
et cette caste et sans vous rien alors
d'une caste sûrement pas ce pas monsieur
jeudi le manga ce n'est sûrement fringe
pratique milieu juno rigide en effet de
manche la touche pas beaucoup
d'importance et j'espère que la france
on ne pourra pas éternellement de
l'origine des uns ou des autres il n'est
pas tant d'avoir une espèce de racisme
en réalité politique ou sociale à cet
égard de toute façon je ne renie jamais
ce que je suis venu voir que je n'ai
jamais pris l'attitude de faciliter ou
de reniement par rapport à quoi que ce
soit et je ne le ferai pas mais par
contre ça ne constitue pas du tout pour
moi un obstacle une différence d'abord
les choses que je suis ce que je suis
devenu je le dois pas du tout à
l'origine je le dois à des concours voix
des élections aura des élections dans
une circonscription qui est typiquement
populaire dans un département qu'une
majorité socialiste pendant des années
donc véritablement ce que je suis dans
la vie politique française vient de ce
que j'ai fait au pas de l'endroit d'où
je viendrai et continuerait par la suite
à avoir les rapports vont peut être les
plus durs avec les plus simples avec
tous ceux avec lesquels j'ai eu
l'occasion de travailler je le sais vous
méditer vous travailler seul et il vrai
que lorsque vous travaillez vous est
inabordable constaterait et jeunes de
même dans d'autres nous n'en créons
centre où est très concentré et ça ça
tient soulève une méthode de travail
parce que quelqu'un qui est celle au
fond des choses et qui s est d' aller
relativement vite au fond des choses
parce que je crois que je vois de
délayer l'analyse d'une situation peut
être capable de trancher assez vite
d'autre part quand je fais des disques
où je le fais moi-même bon vous savez
très bien qu écrire composer un discours
de secours par les 1h30 2h ça très beau
travail qui prend du temps alors à spa
voilà en effet je me concerne je me
concentre seul mais c'est une méthode
soit de travail vous êtes tolérant et
constant dans votre tolérance
j'ai horreur de l'intolérance d'abord je
crois n'avoir jamais pratiqué la
tolérance et j'ai horreur de
l'intolérance et lorsqu'il n'ya aucune
société quelconque la manifestation
d'intolérance j'ai horreur de cette
intolérance je dirais même que les au
cours des dernières années dans certains
mouvements dont certaines tendances de
la jeunesse française qui est une
tendance
jonas extrêmement vivante est capable
avec nous allons voir arriver au pouvoir
se situent des caractéristiques de
l'époque actuelle
il y a un trait par exemple que j'ai
regrettés je ne comprends pas que chez
certains d'entre eux une certaine
intolérance
vous croyez à la méchanceté à la grèce
dégagez forme d'aujourd'hui oui pratique
être très méchant mais très intéressés
n'ont jamais d'être mues alors il peut
bien marcher vous une agressivité
entrées ce qui est encore pire
non je crois vraiment très difficile
d'avoir des questions pareil je crois
vraiment en avoir aucune forme de
méchanceté
je ne crois pas d'agressivité j'en sais
rien parce que tout le monde est
vraiment peu emporté naturellement moi
aussi mais la méchanceté c'est à dire le
désir de blessés de chercher la partie
ferme faire mal c'est vraiment je crois
quelque chose que votre courtoisie c'est
une politesse ou saisonnalité tenait
l'un et l'autre non je le sens
l'existence de deux autres une victoire
si vous aviez cette victoire lundi
pourrait être également considéré comme
une défaite vous y avez pensé
moi j'aurais agi suivant les 50 50 je
m'en tire au dernier sondage
ben j'ai regretté qu'on donne cette
présentation à la campagne
présidentielle est donné oui à la télé
je crois qu'une mauvaise action si noah
des actions parce qu'il faut bien
comprendre de toute façon il y a deux
candidats notre système présidentiel et
ses deux candidats l'un aura un peu plus
de 50% l'autre aura un peu moins de 50%
quel qu'il soit mais c'est la règle du
jeu ne coupe pas la france en douce et
la modalités de désignation du président
la république et donc l'idée que parce
que pour choisir un prétendant la clique
il y a deux candidats ça veut dire que
les français vont se battre entre eux
c'est à mon avis une très mauvaise
présentation aussi rendre un très
mauvais service que de décrire les
choses comme celles là
dans cette affaire les français ne se
pâques par les uns contre les autres ils
ont à choisir ils ont à choisir entre
deux hommes qui représentent deux
tendances de conception de l'avenir
politique de la france mais un le choix
ne comporte pas mes yeux de victoire ou
de l'effet est par exemple ou pour moi
les français qui ne voteront pas pour
moi le 19 mai ne sont pas du tout des
français dont je me dirai en me
réveillant le 20 mai ces français ont
été vains que je me dirai simplement ils
ont fait un autre soi et j'essaierai
d'ailleurs par la suite si je suis élu
de leur faire sentir pourquoi finalement
le choix qui a été fait par la majorité
des français était le meilleur pour vous
l'importance et l'elysée c'est le
couronnement de vos ambitions
non non pour moi ce qui est important je
suis dans une grande confrontation
nationale dont je mesure l'ampleur et je
dirais c'est très très impressionnant
pour quelqu'un qui n'a pas cinquante ans
de se dire que c'est aux jouets beaucoup
avec votre âge non parce qu'il est lent
vous savez comme nous reconnaissent pas
là j'ai toujours là et puis il est là
jusqu'à ce qu'ils s'en aillent
alors c'est quand même très important
quand on a pas cinquante ans de se dire
que l'on représente pour pour ses
compatriotes la possibilité d'un choix
basket est très frappant d'un premier
tour de la campagne présidentielle pour
moi c'est que j'avais pas d'organisation
pratiquement et donc ceux qui ont voté
pour moi
ils ont voté pour m'aider ils n'ont pas
voté pour le parti intel ou pour le
syndicat intel ils ont voté pour m'aider
donc 1 8 million trois cent mille
personnes qui ont voté pour m'aider et
callian me l'ont dit parce qu'ils ont
été créés hui se sont manifestés coptes
comme super leurs accords pas alors ce
qui est important s'ils voulaient pour
moi c'est pas l'elysée spa c'est pas
imaginer que la semaine prochaine je
franchirai le porche ovale de lady di
non ce n'est pas ça c'est de représenter
un certain choix pour france vous fait
des promesses démagogiques
ce que vous promettez pourquoi ne l'avez
vous pas accordé plus tôt devant ne sont
pas démagogique
je veux pas envie de vous la mettez y
mais je promets j'ouvre un certain
nombre de perspectives parce qu'il aura
un avenir mais votre question est très
intéressante parce que là dessus il ya
une volonté des gares et les français
ont dit comment se fait il que quelqu'un
propose quelque chose pour l'avenir
qu'il n'a pas fait dans le passé
c'est toujours le cas car il ya toujours
quelque chose d'autre à faire supposez
que je me suis le terran sois moi-même
soyons président la république bien à la
fin de notre mandat
il y aura encore d'autres choses à faire
nous n'irons pas là le monde s'arrête
parce que notre mandat s'arrête alors en
1974 il y a des choses à décider pour
l'avenir et de même qu'au cours des
dernières années nous avons fait
beaucoup de tours de la france a fait
beaucoup de choses et je regrette que
dans cette campagne présidentielle on
cherche à lui faire croire qu'elle n'a
rien fait parce que vous circulez dans
le monde
je vais fait aussi vous savez très bien
tout le monde considère que la france
est appliquée énormément progressé et on
dit mais en effet ce qui s'est passé en
france est très remarquable alors l'idée
que la france est restée les bras
croisés depuis dix ans une idée qui est
injuste pour la réalité française
mais il ya toujours d'autres choses à
faire si vous étiez président de la
république et s'il en est est encore
prendriez vous monsieur françois
mitterrand comme premier ministre mais
dans la porte
oui j'ai gâché importante et qu'il ya un
choix clair à faire c'est un choix entre
deux organisations économiques et
sociales qui sont très différentes de
celles que je propose d'une part celle
que propose monsieur mitterrand et elles
sont très différentes
or pour moi la règle dans la politique
c'est la clarté puisque les françoises
les français choisiront un certain type
d'organisation pour que les hommes qui
conduisent la politique et dans l'esprit
ce type d'organisation donc compte tenu
du choix monsieur propre mitterrand à
l'heure actuelle je vous réponds non
par contre il se trouve que dans ce
qu'était le parti de monsieur mitterrand
lorsqu'il est la cinquième république
c'est-à-dire lui dsr il y à beaucoup
d'hommes la plupart d'entre eux qui ont
opté en ma faveur
si monsieur mitterrand était resté en
somme dans ce parti le fait quelqu'un
qui aurait eu vocation à participer au
vote pour l'avenir vous pourriez dire
non mais pour un socialiste je voudrais
vous poser une dernière question vous
connaissez cette phrase de michel est le
difficile n'est pas de monter mais en
montant de rester soi
non ce n'est pas difficile de rester soi
et je veux dire c'est ne pas pour moi le
problème j'espère rester moi je perds me
perfectionner un peu mais j'espère
rester mois dans le difficile
en réalité c'est de rester avec les
autres comme les autres ce n'est pas
d'être soi même c'est être aussi
possible aussi semblables que possible
aux autres c'est d'être comme les autres
[Musique]